well 9/11 played a critical role in the
lives of so many Americans certainly in
the life of congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard
of Hawaii she joined the military
immediately following the attacks and
subsequently served a tour in Iraq now
she's running for president we'll talk
about that in a minute but first
congresswoman Gabbard joins us tonight
to talk about 9/11 congressman thanks a
lot for coming on so what I'm looking
back you've had time to think about this
both in this country and abroad what are
the lessons for the rest of us from 9/11
would you say 18 years later yeah it's
it's you know looking back on that day
remembering where we were and as we
observed al-qaeda attacking us and
seeing the thousands of our fellow
Americans who were killed on that day
and and seeing the brave acts that that
these heroes our first responders before
it as they ran they ran into those
crumbling buildings as so many people
were trying to get out to see how many
people they could save you know like so
many Americans it was this event that
made me decide in my own life that I
wanted to dedicate my life to keeping
the American people safe to finding and
defeating those who attacked us on that
day and to to protecting our freedoms
this is something that continues to
inspire me today but also we've got to
recognize how much our leaders have
failed us where instead of focusing one
pointedly on defeating al Qaeda and its
affiliates and and offshoots instead
they went and started waging a series of
regime change wars in places like Iraq
and Libya and the ongoing regime change
war in Syria now this has cost our
country trillions of taxpayer dollars we
have lost thousands of American lives in
these wars my brothers and sisters in
uniform what to speak of the countless
lives lost in these other countries in
the Middle East and where do we find
ourselves today al Qaeda is stronger now
than they were on 9/11 this is the
result that we have so I have to say I'm
completely convinced that if you would
leave the line about sea
out if you would pretend that what we're
doing in Syria and have done in Syria's
is wise and smart that you would be on
the stage with your fellow Democrats at
the debate bringing up that point about
Syria has earned you the enmity of a lot
of people in Washington a lot the entire
foreign policy establishment I think
it's bad you know what's what's so
interesting though tucker is if you look
back around the vote for the Iraq war
you know there were some folks of the
very few folks who voted against that
Iraq war and they were smeared they were
accused of hating America they were
called unpatriotic and and all of a
sudden now we are where we are today and
it's become vogue for politicians to say
how terrible that Iraq war was yet they
lack the courage to stand up and speak
the truth today against the ongoing
regime change war in Syria that's not
leadership no it's certainly not so how
do you you feel about being excluded
from this from this next DNC debate oh
you know the DNC is trying to basically
send a message to the American people
that they are the all-powerful
gatekeepers and that they are the ones
who have the power to decide who should
be considered to be our Democratic
nominee or not but the reality is that
voters in this country have that power
so that's where I'm focused I'm focused
on reaching out to and connecting with
voters they're the ones I'm committed to
serving yeah you'd think that a party
that says it believes in diversity would
like to have someone with maybe a
different point of view on the issue and
you have a different point of view on
some of those issues and I think that's
that's part of the problem with with
with these debates is you know with
these 30-second answers 60-second
answers you're not really giving voters
the chance to hear where do we stand on
these issues what motivates us why are
we doing what we're doing
what experience and credibility do we
bring to this job of President and this
huge responsibility of serving as
commander-in-chief and so really all
become
is is a opportunity for the hosting
media network to get high ratings or or
make some money off of it and and it's
just you know the whole things are
charade and it and it doesn't serve
voters that's that's really the biggest
problem here noticed congressman Tulsi
Gabbard thank you for that